good morning believe nation today's
messages dominate one thing over to you
Elliott Hulse I'm reading a really
fascinating book right now called
the one thing can't remember the name of
the author right now but you can look it
up on Amazon and this author asserts and
I found this to be true in my own
experience and that's why I find the
book so fascinating he asserts that if
you put all of your eggs in one basket
like Andrew Carnegie once said and just
watch that basket grow you will reach
your greatest success and that basically
means you choose one thing and you
dominate that one thing and it will if
you choose the right thing and we'll
talk about that a moment if you choose
the right one or what I've also heard
described as or called the keystone
habit you choose the habit that's
associated with dominating one thing it
will inevitably trickle over into all
other areas of your life you will see
success in other areas if you just
dominate this one thing it's also been
described as the Pareto principle or the
80/20 rule that whereby all of yours
they say 80% of your results will come
from 20% of your efforts the trick is to
try to figure out what is that 20%
require you know which one of these
things do i hack hack at you know put
all my time effort energy talent and
faculty into dominating so that it will
have a tremendous effect on everything
else if you look at the people who've
had the most success in any field it's
because of their ability to focus on
what they're doing you set a goal for
one thing that you want to accomplish
and you don't stop you don't quit you
don't get distracted until you achieve
that outcome and I see too many
entrepreneurs coming to me and say Evan
I want to diversify my income streams
right I gotta find other ways to bring
in money and it's usually coming from
two places that I find one is
desperation and
one is boredom and it's talking about
desperation that's the more common one
really it's because you haven't made
enough money from your passion from what
you're really excited about from your
business and you have to pay the bills
right I got a put food on the table I
got to pay for my internet bill right I
got to pay for electricity all that
stuff I'm not talking about lavish
luxury lifestyle living just pay the
bills right and so the interesting thing
is you get forced into a situation we
try to find other businesses that you
can start and run but if you haven't had
success with the business that you are
passionate about and that you know a lot
about and that you're improving yourself
on then how do you expect to have
success in businesses that you know
nothing about and that you're not
passionate about you're doing it just
for the money you're probably not right
and then you end up in this loop of
having to spread your time across all of
these different businesses and none of
them ever doing really well because
you're doing everything in a mediocre
way instead of going all-in on something
and being really successful at it now it
can take time to reach your goal and you
will have to learn and you will have to
get better you will have stumbling
blocks along the way and sometimes that
means you get desperate need to make
money the solution that I would have is
maybe a little off the wall from what
you might be thinking but it'd be the go
get a job go work for somebody because
the reason the work isn't just to make
money and that's the mistake most people
make they work to make money and that's
that's the worst reason to go and get a
job you get a job yes to make money but
to learn right look at your business
look at why it's not working and see
like what's the skill that you're
missing what are you just not getting
and how can you acquire that by going to
work for somebody who's going to teach
you right go find a job at a company
that that you want to be like in five to
ten years and get the as close to the
founder as possible learn from them
you're getting paid to make mistakes to
make connections to understand how the
industry works meanwhile you're still
working on your business every single
day 30 60 90 120 minutes plus every
single day to move your dream forward
you're still hustling and so the
solution isn't diversify your income
streams and start other businesses
because it's a desperation play and you
end up not getting to where you want to
go and people see taking a job as a step
back but it's really not if you're
learning through that process I don't
think you'll get a job at McDonald's
sipping burgers right unless you're
trying to start a
food chain you'll get a job where you're
gonna learn something and make money and
make connections and pour that knowledge
into your business to make you better
entrepreneur the second time I hear is
when people are are bored really if you
dig deep down and why are they saying
that is because they're bored with their
business and it happens to a lot of
entrepreneurs we've been around for a
while number of years maybe your
business has made a lot of money maybe
it's just provided for you at some point
a lot of entrepreneurs get bored and
it's often because usually this is what
happens you grow as a person right you
have different interests different
skills you have different habits you
want to explore different areas and when
you started your business that was all
aligned right what you were excited
about and passionate was aligned and
that's what made the business come to
life but over time you went here and
your business kept going on that
straight line and the more time goes on
the more you guys diverge and the less
and less interesting your business
becomes the mistake is that your
business didn't adjust as you adjust it
as a human being as you develop new
passions and interests your business
needs to sway with you your business
should always be a reflection of who you
are is individual right my business is
always a reflection of Who I am and what
I'm interested in I wasn't doing YouTube
videos ten years ago because I don't
even know if you to exists it if it did
I wasn't on it I was doing only the
website and if I just stopped doing the
website then I would be pretty bored
right now and say I need I need
something new right the challenges you
want to have growth and if you feel
you're not growing anymore in your
business then you seek it elsewhere as
human beings crave growth and so your
two options are one change your business
with you whatever you're excited about
now go and do that or if it's just if
it's just you got to get rid of it you
know you don't want to do it anymore you
can't change it to match your needs then
sell it find somebody who can buy and
then you go off and start something new
because you just hanging on hanging on
hanging on to the business it's not
going to grow anymore it's gonna start
off just going steady and then over time
it's going to decrease because you're
not putting the love into it you don't
really care about as much anymore you're
not innovating anymore and your business
gonna start to decline and so you want
to sell it now when the price could
still be something high you get a return
on it we're in
five years after it's gone down you
won't be able to sell it anymore sell it
now move on to something else
always follow your passion so the real
power the real success the real
domination comes when you focus on one
thing and see it through to its
execution and if you can't then it's
often because of that separation or
because of boredom and hopefully giving
you some strategies to be able to attack
that in your business in your life
believe so the question today today is
maybe going a little deep are you
desperate or bored in your business
leave it in the comments below and I'm
going to join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching have an amazing
day continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso